hey youtubers is Charlie so the Game of
Thrones Season 4 finale just aired it
was called the children in it aired on
Father's Day which i think is just
brilliant planning on HBO's part there's
a lot of stuff we need to talk about but
real quick shout out for the giveaway
just because you guys have been so
awesome I'm tripling the giveaway I'm
just picking three random subscribers
from the comments on this video and I'm
just giving a $20 Amazon gift card to
each I'll announce who the winners are
in my Q&A video tomorrow night because
so many of you asked for a super long
finale video I compromised and instead
of focusing on like five really big WTF
moments I'm going to do ten then I'll do
my review I briefly mentioned some
season 5 stuff but I'm going to do a
separate predictions video tomorrow for
that so careful for spoilers if you
haven't seen the episode yet but here we
go
number 10 manse and Jon drink to dearly
departed gingers mance is such an
interesting character he knows Jon Snow
better than he knows himself in case you
didn't catch it last season mance used
to be a brother of the Nights Watch so
he knows all their tricks and that they
have nothing left there's basically no
one left there so the negotiation was
more about mance convincing John of his
sincerity you know they didn't want to
conquer Westeros they just wanted to
hide behind the wall before the White
Walkers invaded the haunted forest they
were inside the haunted forest that was
where that camp was it's just north of
the wall and it was actually pretty
close to the weirwood where Jon burned
Egrets body number 9
Stannis attacks the wildlings this was
such an awesome reveal I'd seen all the
teasers for the episode but for some
reason my brain still thought White
Walkers whenever that horn blew it was
also one of the best special effects
sequences in the episode if you've never
played it the opening title sequence you
know with all the miniatures is an O Maj
to the board game so I felt like this
scene was also an O Maj to that just
with the way the camera panned out and
just showed both of those armies
attacking from both sides I also thought
it was a thematic call out to the title
of book 3 Storm of Swords with the swarm
of men just charging in I think the most
exciting part was when the camera panned
over and you see the other part of the
army on the other side of the haunted
forest almost like it's going to be a
slow-moving train wreck you know
something so amazing that you just
cannot look away from that's actually a
good metaphor for the episode like the
whole episode was a slow-moving train
wreck that you just cannot look away
from number 8 Qyburn saves the mountain
I'm a huge fan of Frankenstein and Bride
of Frankenstein
so using Qyburn in the mountainous
analogues for those characters is so
much
on those films are such big touch-tones
for Hollywood filmmakers I always love
it when directors pay homage to them
like when pycelle called it his
laboratory and he referenced the fact
that Qyburn had been thrown out of the
Citadel for experimenting with
necromancy it's not necromancy like the
White Walkers practiced like their magic
he was using chemistry and it looked
like he was in the process of
transfusing the mountains blood out like
the manticore poisoned blood although we
did not see what he was replacing it
with that's something we can follow up
on in my season 5 predictions video if
you've read the books please use the
spoiler tag when commenting about the
mountain please I always love to see
fantasy crossover with science fiction
and I felt like this scene that
Frankenstein scene really did that
number 7
Cersei threatens Tywin with her twincest
the biggest surprise of this scene was
the genuine WTF face Tywin made I always
thought that he knew what was going on
and just chose not to let on like he was
too proud to let any of his outrage show
Circe's threat was that she was just
gonna tell anyone that would listen
about her twincest with Jaime
if Tywin marched her down the aisle she
was definitely more motivated by her
love for Tommen than her desire to not
get buried again but yeah she really did
not want to be married to anyone even if
there weren't any social restrictions I
feel like given the choice she would not
choose to marry Jaime to be fair though
the Targaryens married brother to sister
for the entire history of their family I
think the reason that people didn't call
them out on it was because they had
dragons to barbecue any critics I also
really loved the follow-up to the scene
with Jaime whenever he was reading the
white book and he just pushed it off the
table like a glass of wine when they
started to have sex the white book is a
literary representation of the honorable
deeds previous Kingsguard brothers have
done so by casting it off the table
Jaime was basically throwing away his
honor
it's like Cersei is his heroine and he's
been trying to quit all season it just
cannot do it
number six Daenerys has to chain her
dragons up anyone who has had to crate
train a puppy will understand how sad
this was as many WTF moments as they're
worn in the episode this was one of the
only ones I did not cheer for this was
actually something that did happen in
the books drogon starts to accidentally
kill people vissarion and regal are the
only ones that get chained up because
drogon is still roaming free in the
countryside so we're not going to see
him again till next season the other big
takeaway from this is that Dragons that
get chained up generally do not grow as
large as dragons they just roam free
so drug on is just going to continue to
get bigger and bigger until they chain
him up or if they ever chain him up
number five John Burns Ygritte under the
weirwood this actually reminded me a
little bit of Return of the Jedi when
Luke burned his father Darth Vader's
body in the forest that tree is the same
weirwood where he took his knights watch
oh I love how a bunch of different
characters eulogized Ygritte like
they're just recognizing what an amazing
character she is I really hope that
someday she and Kit Harington get to
work together in a movie or another TV
show it would just be so much fun number
four bran meets the three-eyed Raven and
the children of the forest this felt
like one of the most important events on
the show like bran was going to be
crowned king of the forest like Luke
Skywalker meeting Yoda for the first
time Yoda always knew that Luke was
going to come learn from him just like
the three-eyed Raven had been watching
bran and the other characters their
whole lives if you didn't catch it
whenever he said I've had many names
it's just a reference to his identities
before he became the green seer whenever
he was alive he was a Targaryen bastard
named the Bloodraven he was the son of
Aegon the fourth the king that
precipitated the Blackfyre rebellion I
did a bonus video for the Bloodraven a
little while ago so I'll put a link in
the description if you want to learn
more about that character I could do a
whole video about bran at that weird
with that whole big sequence the homage
to Ray Harryhausen with the skeleton
warriors that's actually from Clash of
the Titans Harryhausen was this really
famous visual effects creator whose
style just looked like this he did it
with real-life models because it was
before the age of digital effects but
now that the children of the forest are
on the show I can't wait to see how
brand story unfolds as it relates to
them and the White Walkers and this big
greater war that's going on number three
Brienne versus the Hound Battle Royale
this is one of the biggest changes from
the books but originally the Hound still
did die in the books he was just killed
by people seeking the bounty on his head
they also didn't do the Lady Stoneheart
character which is who Brienne ended up
burning it to in the books so because
they got rid of these two big plot
points they had to do this shootout at
the okay Vale Corral between brain and
the Hound just to rain the story back in
before it got too far away from the
books
it was just like them doing that whole
big thing at Craster's house earlier
this season it was something from the
books that they had to include to tie up
a bunch of loose plots because the
things they changed earlier in the
season so it's just like the ripple
effect you know as you get further
further along on this story the changes
get
bigger and bigger until they do
something to kind of rein it back in and
that's what this was for but number two
aria refuses to kill the Hound Aria is
so cold now it's actually hard to read
her face I think she knew the Hound was
just trying to go Terron into mercy
killing him but because he couldn't read
her he just kept escalating things
trying to find out what would make her
so mad that she'd do it inside I think
that he secretly did not wish that he
had actually visited all those [ __ ] on
Sansa I think he really just wanted to
die and he was just willing to say
anything to get her to kill him I
totally loved that she did not it shows
that she's even darker than you thought
remember where the heart is Aria you're
headed to Braavos the coin scene was
right out of the books and isn't it
convenient that a Braavosi ship just
happened to be sitting there in the port
she was near it should be noted though
that she did try to join John at the
wall so that could have been possible in
like an alternate timeline because they
kept Braavos in the opening credits for
so many episodes I was pretty sure they
were gonna do this scene eventually
Braavos is actually one of the coolest
places we're gonna get to visit Nick
season I've already done a bonus video
for that so I'll put another link in the
description in case you want to learn
more about it but my number one WTF
moment of course
Tyrion kills Tywin and Shae their whole
relationship distilled into three long
minutes there's so many things that
stand out at this sequence first off
there was the big change with Tyrion and
Jaime the way that he left them was a
big change from the books I'd say it was
this big of a change as the brand in the
Hound scene in the books Jamie told
Tyrion that his first wife was not a
[ __ ] and Tywin just made her go away so
Tyrion vows revenge on his entire family
the way this show changed it allows them
to hold on to that brotherly bond
between them Jaime and Tyrion will
always love each other as opposed to the
books where Tyrion hates everyone is
this change that I'm really happy with
and I'm interested to see if it comes
back around in the future season at some
point the Shae scene where he kills her
is actually really close to the books
too he choked her with his father's gold
chain of office the chains at the hand
of the king where's they showed the
chain dangling but it was kind of hard
to see if you weren't looking for it who
else got goosebumps whenever Peter
Dinklage was dragging the crossbow on
his way to Tywin I actually did believe
him when Tywin said that he never
planned for tearing to die like he was
never going to let him be killed
my favorite moment though was the reload
not Tywin's words not the speech just
Tyrion casually reloading the crossbow
and shooting him again if you didn't
catch it to whenever they escape varus
turns around and gets on the boat with
him so they're both headed east now it's
your turn though let me know in the
comments below what was your biggest WTF
moment and were there any big surprises
things that you didn't expect I know
it's kind of hard with the show like
Game of Thrones when it's based on a
bunch of books that everyone is already
read I was really surprised by the
Brienne versus the Hound Throwdown and
Stannis arriving at the wall overall I
gave the episode saw an A+ for being my
new favorite game of Thrones finale
I think the way they changed the plot
helped keep it from being too
predictable
even if there were some big book moments
I can't stop thinking about that fight
scene between bran and the Hound I'm
actually wondering if that scene was
part of the reason Gwendoline Christie
got cast in Star Wars Episode seven I'll
go on to say that that fight was almost
as awesome as Oberyn Martell vs. the
mountain it's hard to pick one actor
delivering the best performance in the
episode I will say that Peter Dinklage
and Lena Headey really stood out but
that's not really a surprise
they're two the best actors on the show
Maisie Williams is definitely going to
be someone that you need to watch
closely next season she just keeps
getting better and better Rory McCann
hands-down had the best death in the
episode and probably the series but let
me know in the comments do you think
that anyone on the show had a better
death than the Hound I know we didn't
see him die it just ended with him
yelling at Arya but I don't think he's
going to be coming back next year and I
didn't mention it in my top 10 moments
but Ari and Brienne bonding over being
tomboys was just so much fun I love the
way the show plays with expectations I
thought that she'd be the one to go
after the Hound but it was Ari in the
Hound that went after her for thinking
she was on the Lannister payroll
I mean who among us can't also say that
we would also like a Valyrian blade if
one just happened to walk along I'm
going to dedicate a separate video to
season 5 predictions and plot lines but
things that were pretty clearly
foreshadowed were the mountain turning
into Frankenstein's monster Arya going
to Braavos brand with the green seer and
Stannis at the wall so I'll be posting
that video tomorrow on Monday with my
Q&A be sure to subscribe to get it
after that I'll probably like one more
bonus video during the week and then
I'll just start doing weekly bonus
videos on Sunday so we can still totally
do Game of Thrones Sundays until Season
5 gets here in April so right now click
here to get that Q&A video
and click here to get my season 5 video
a lot of the invitations as soon as I
posted the videos thank you so much for
watching everyone go and we watch the
episode right now
high fives I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you